Hey, nobody's perfect.
Avengers: Endgame might be the biggest movie
in the world, but that doesn't mean that it's
immune from those nagging continuity errors
that can be found in virtually every Hollywood
production, including many of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe entries that came before it.
In case you're not hip to the lingo, a "continuity
error," such as the ones that plagued 2008's
Iron Man, usually happens when a cut between
scenes imply a series of events that, well,
shouldn't be possible, such as a character's
drink suddenly going from empty to full from
one shot to the next.
In Endgame, fans have spotted a pretty egregious
example, and it has to do with Scott Lang.
You may only want to keep watching if you've
seen the flick, because we'll be getting into
some SPOILERS.
The glitch occurs near the end of the film,
during the monumental battle between Thanos
and his invading forces and the Avengers,
alongside all of the returned heroes and the
entire Wakandan army.
But you don't need a whole recap, right?
"Avengers!
So they're fighting this purple guy over the
universe, and then he won, and now you're
here…
Anyway."
During the melee, Lang and Hope Van Dyne are
making their way through the chaos in an attempt
to reach Scott's van, still housing the Quantum
Tunnel.
It's a nifty little scene, with Ant-Man and
the Wasp suddenly thrust back into action
together once again… but the very next shot
is a wide one of the two opposing forces clashing
on the battlefield.
There, in the middle of it all, is Lang in
his Giant-Man form.
Whoops!
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo have been
going gangbusters explaining to the press
some of Endgame's perceived plot holes and
mistakes, but unless they're going to tell
us that it was actually Hank Pym or Bill Foster
wearing an extra Ant-Man suit or something,
we're pretty sure this is a big old fat error
that falls directly on the film's editors.
Film productions generally employ one or more
"script supervisors" whose job it is to make
sure that seemingly insignificant details
remain consistent between multiple takes of
the same scene.
When they drop the ball, things can start
getting a little glitchy, but often, such
as in the case of this scene, it comes down
to a simple oversight during the editing stage.
If the sequence had been cut differently,
it may have appeared that Lang had left Van
Dyne on her own in order to "go big" and rejoin
the fray, but as it stands, he appears to
be in two places at the same time.
Ant-Man may be resourceful, but he's no Loki.
As we previously mentioned, it can be nearly
impossible to squeeze every last continuity
error out of a film, editors are often left
with a less-than-desirable choice of shots
to piece together, and continuity can be tough
to maintain when various takes of the same
scene are shot weeks apart, for example.
The Mighty Marvel Cinematic Universe is no
exception, and trained as its rabid fans are
to always be on the lookout for tiny, Easter
egg-y details, very few of its continuity
errors go unnoticed.
The "Goofs" section of the IMDb page for inaugural
entry Iron Man alone lists a whopping two
dozen mistakes in continuity, including Stark's
tip disappearing from the tip jar, the color
of the camera lens on Tony's phone changing
between cuts, and even the length of Stark's
goatee going from pencil-thin to full and
fuzzy over the course of one short night.
Mistakes such as these are pretty easy to
spot if you're on the lookout for them, and
let's face it, the only real surprise here
is that this is the only continuity error
that has been spotted in Endgame so far.
With the flick only having been in theaters
for a short time, it probably won't be long
before fans going back for repeat viewings
point out a bunch more.
Does it seem a little bit ridiculous for such
an easily-spotted gaffe to show up in such
a highly-anticipated box office juggernaut
of a film?
A little bit, sure.
Does said gaffe diminish our enjoyment of
Avengers: Endgame even one iota?
Absolutely not.
Then again, it's a little tougher than usual
to zero in on tiny onscreen errors when you're
crying tears of pure joy.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.